hello citizens of the reject nation we
got john here to do the entire intro
isn't that right john that's right guys
it's time for season three episode 17 of
brooklyn nine nine if you could go ahead
and put the title of the episode the
title of the episode uh is you're
slowing down the intro we gotta get
there a minute at the time
john it's the jason man sukis one is the
title of this it's adrian pimento i
remembered it if you could go ahead and
leave a like on this video we would very
much appreciate that comment your
favorite moment from the episode and
when you're done with that hit the
subscribe button and the notification
bell get notified every time
oh geez uh and hey conversationally
speaking if you would like to come on
over to our patreon and see the full
episode sync up with your own copy you
can do that
throughout the number two jesus and uh
bring us to your local bank location and
just give us a few bucks just out of
your own pocket or whatever that would
be very much appreciated and hey prepper
the boys and girls and everyone in
between at prepper thanks for making
these highlights happen and you guys
most of all thank you for being here
thank you greg for having me you're
welcome well i conceived you thank you
for being my father
i've learned a lot frizzy over time
let's watch brooklyn
can i show you something over here
you're thinking about trying to send
genevieve a sexy pic just move my bubble
butt
who's that i don't know excuse me pal
take care of my desk
squad meet detective adrian pimento he's
been deep undercover for the last 12
years
he's rejoining the nine-nine
that
is
awesome
[Laughter]
some of you just met detective pimento
and of course some of you knew him
before he went undercover hitchcock and
scully
you guys still work here the only way
they're getting rid of us is in a body
bag it actually happened once but it was
a false alarm
what'd you do undercover i worked for
jimmy the butcher figgis tell me
literally everything everyone shut up
pretty much just a bag man for him i did
some other stuff
[Laughter]
about to learn not to blink because
every time i close my eyes i see a fresh
horror oh dark but how do you keep your
eyes moist no actually i have a very
funny story about keeping my eyes moist
[Laughter]
nope
still not getting our vibe man really um
i'll get there that's my bad everybody
dismissed
[Laughter]
such a funny setup psychologically this
could be a very difficult transition
yeah i know i went undercover 63 days no
big deal you probably forgot hey it's
jake i can't get to the phone right now
i might be undercover again like i was
for 63.
[Laughter]
let me be the man that brings him in
from the cold all right he can work the
b e with you just make sure you take it
easy uh sir i was 20 minutes late for
work today i don't think you need to
tell me about taking it easy are you
bragging about being a bad employee
dismissed
the best way to welcome pimento to the
nine-nine stay out of his way maybe buy
him a drink not do anything weird i'm
making him a goat stew huh all right
with pimentos
i even ordered the pressure cooker from
turkmenistan so you're on a terrace
watch list now oh yeah homeland
security's been in my house yep now this
just needs to cook for another 11 hours
32 minutes and six pass
terry's gonna die saving the president
or terry's never gonna die there's no
way we can clean this up by ourselves
we're gonna need help what are you
saying you know what she's saying man
oh no
mean marge
so we're supposed to come running
together
i'm gonna do a simple straightforward
tour of the precinct featuring detective
diaz of me i can be dynamic
exclamation point diaz and i have that
kind of easy chemistry where we finish
each other's sentences please don't
interrupt me
[Laughter]
tell me something you've never told
another living soul i'm actually not
strong enough to lift a water cooler jug
so i always find a way to make terry do
it here's mine jimmy the butcher made me
drive a croquet wicked threw a guy's
eyes into his brain brain leaked out his
eyes like he was crying his own mind
[Music]
now that i've heard yours i feel like my
water cooler thing could be a little
more juicy but no that was embarrassing
for you
a bond has been made
yeah well i'm not gonna bone gizmo i
would be careful with the mentos it's
gonna be fine
[Music]
hey partner no i've been waiting for you
[Laughter]
this was a mistake i'm not ready i knew
i wasn't ready to go back to being
police the only job i've ever had except
for a bag of groceries at the
supermarket at the corner of atlantic
and clinton
i guess i could go back to that again
paper or plastic still got it listen to
me
i thought you were just gonna be looking
through the files or something man tai
chi helps keep the demons at bay
do you have to do it in your underwear i
can't take them off cause then you'd be
looking right at my penis and testicles
this delivery is great
we're just gonna go over mean marge's
head and we're gonna tell holt tell me
what oh well i don't know if you noticed
but there was an accident in the break
room yesterday oh yes
shattered windows bones everywhere it's
very new york in the 70s clean it up
uh-huh
marge in facilities is refusing to help
we were actually hoping maybe you could
ask her i've taken a sacred oath to
protect this community and that is a job
i take seriously so you're afraid of her
too huh terrified
and don't worry sir we're gonna catch
these bastards or my name isn't paul
snead adrian pimento adrian pimento so
what'd they take
dolls worth the stuff tvs cameras a
bunch of prepaid cell phones ooh you
sell burner phones
what kind of deals you got on those why
do you want to know about the deals just
gathering evidence for the case cause
i'm a cop remember detective paul sneed
[Laughter]
come on man
look i get it
you're still tense
when i came back from being undercover
they made me see a shrink but then he
told me i had dad issues and i was like
you know what you can't tell me what to
do you're not my dad so he was a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'll be right back i just left something
inside
all the burner phones
why are you buying a burner phone
two smoke machine
and action hulk
welcome to the nine-nine i'm captain
raymond holt
and i'm detective rosa diaz
i don't understand why i'm on a
wheelchair cut the wheelchair will turn
into a horse but i need you to work with
me this is idiotic maybe because you
didn't karate chop your way through the
smoke as scripted i'm out scully rosa
i can't believe i'm gonna sleep with him
well
you don't have to nah i'm gonna man bolt
cutters bolt cutters have literally
never been used by an innocent person i
use them all the time when i make
jewelry what
rosa pimento just put on a ski mask and
broke into a creepy abandoned warehouse
hmm that's hot
i take him down in the break room now
it's a whole crime scene and then we can
get crime scene cleaners that room gets
clean when i say it gets cleaned you
can't stop us now you ever heard the old
saying no the garbage no the man i know
all your secrets oh
those aren't mine i only eat locally
sourced meats there could be terries he
was fat once you know what the hell
boyle speaking of shepherds
maybe your daughters would like to know
that their daddy throws away all their
drawings oh that's terrible
maybe the world would like to see that
draft of a memo you wrote where you use
t-h-e-i-r instead of t-h-e-r-e oh you
sick son of a [ __ ] why do you hate us
so much i know you call me mean marge
do you even know my last name hmm mom
bucket scully don't get it
it's good alliteration okay great take
you guys are finally getting it all
right let's go again action
halt
welcome to the nine-nine no
and i'm detective rosa diaz he what the
[ __ ] you see
he really understands the craft
is that
i'm trying to put my finger on it yeah
it's like urkel
it's not
gina this is a disgrace i'm removing you
as director there he goes
i have to take more belts
oh yeah
suck it roadside assistance
well well well oh
i can't believe you're still working for
figgis that's why you've been acting so
weird breaking into my apartment buying
a burner phone grabbing this duffel i
broke into your apartment because i
didn't feel safe at my home okay and a
bird phone's the only kind of phone i
can get because i disappeared for 12
years and now have terrible credit make
sense
the duffel
open it up tough guy
a bunch of old family photos and
personal belongings pimentos mementos
i'm with you i couldn't have them
finding anything that could trace back
to my family i get it all right i went
through the exact same thing when i came
back you have no clue what i've been
through i can't believe i trusted you
let's get out of here jake
oh my god this guy's got a pancake butt
it's not peninsula get out of there jake
[Laughter]
i can't do this i'm better off as a bag
man oh no you think he went back to work
with figgis worse
fine single bag it it's your funeral you
dumb son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the footage came back on that benny and
we've got a suspect i'm going to bust
him right now if you want to come with
me why don't you give me those eggs i'll
put them on top here okay
what was that about what happened to you
maggie butt out okay this is my life
what did you send them a cinematic
masterpiece is what i sent them did it
feature pizzazz no none at all sir
first i couldn't wrap my head around
that concept but then i realized do you
know which dogs get the most likes on
the internet anatolian shepherds
ugly little runts with wonky eyes and
tongues that won't stay in their mouths
but the anatolian shepherd is unrivaled
for protecting livestock
we were trying our hardest but this is a
disgrace disgrace
he cleaned up the stoop which means the
marge bronigan break room is open for
business well take out your trash do
normal cleaning but no big messes great
time for the christening no
[Music]
oh
crap congratulations
perp is on the third floor everyone know
your assignment mind if i tag along
pimento yeah i thought about it if you
say things will get back to normal then
i trust you
oh no
let's do this you're with me partner
[Music]
nypd you're under arrest you're gonna
die
[Laughter]
what an ending oh man
dude that's my favorite guest star
character ever
hilarious that was funny he was from
hell from getting it
he's just he's he he has a really good
grip on like the midpoint between like
really committing to the character
taking it seriously but having like the
i don't know there's the absurdity to
pay off like the comedy perfectly yeah
he was so funny
that was so funny that what a great like
i i don't know if i've seen that at one
of these cop comedies before
just a character who's
been undercover for so long and he's
just as we've seen that character i'm
someone who's like
lost between you know good and bad and
like what is my real identity
yeah we've seen that done before but i
don't know if i've ever seen it handled
so well with a comedic flair to it and
yeah i mean
jason um oh my god look at his last name
mandzukic yep yeah jason manzoukis is um
i mean i've seen him like do comedy
before he's
he's hilarious but
as this character i'm like oh man i want
to see more of this character he's such
a you like root for him you want him
like you you're always like kind of on
edge like ah crap how's he gonna react
to this movement but you also like want
him to get better like you care about
him yeah but he's so funny too oh man
that was that was really impressive and
i love like the dark humor at the very
top just like
how the the joke of the cut away is just
it's so violent and they don't try don't
try to make it funny at all
dark it's messed up
messed up
and that's just what makes it funny is
the reaction afterwards
oh man that was really
that was that was hilarious that was a
hilarious ass character and i'm really
really rude of room and i hope he i hope
we get more of him yeah that was the
thing is at the end of the episode i was
like man i would like to i would have
him as like a serious regular from now
on just like as part of
the dynamic because that's such an
interesting story and there's so much
you could do with that over time like
it's a great one-off gag but at the same
time and in a show that you know like
isn't the most serialized but does pay
attention to its characters and does
incorporate some of their history like
that could actually be a really fun
thing to watch as he plays off of
not just jake but all sorts of different
characters you know well they set him up
like he's a new character that's how it
feels yeah i don't know if it's going to
be a new character but they set him up
like he's a new character for the show
yeah i mean i hope in this moment i
would hope so i mean it's one of those
things i've never heard his name like
heavily attached to the show so i guess
i don't assume so but i would love that
man cause like he's he has
i haven't seen everything he's been in
but he does every time he shows up kind
of have this knack for these like wild
eyed like crazed
characters who are teetering on the edge
of of normalcy and uh and yeah like he
has something that's kind of different
from everybody else in the ensemble too
so you're like oh that could actually
work and he's also believable as as a
guy who could be like a beat cop
you know he's believable as that guy who
has been disgruntled and been undercover
you could see him as the guy you would
send undercover and you could see him as
a street cop
you know it's like perfectly for i don't
know what the process was with bringing
this character life if they wrote around
him or if they had an opportunity to
bring him into the show so they created
this character i don't know but damn
that was like that that was a perfect
guest star role my opinion that was
perfect yeah a lot of times these guests
are roles i can get excited about but
then i ultimately i'm like yeah they're
great or they do a good job but that
that was the first one where i'm like i
really hope we get more than because
we've seen like the comedy ones like
we've got bill hader in here we've had
pat and oswald who had nick crawl
craig robinson i mean craig robinson's
pretty perfect casting too but yeah this
is he still is a different kind of yeah
yeah he's doing his craig robinson thing
and that's the entire charm whereas this
is like yes he's a refreshing character
yeah there's something really refreshing
about this character yeah it's like the
perfect blend of character and actor
yeah there's no other way to put it that
was that was freaking awesome that was
hilarious yeah and uh the b stories were
fun too the trash story was kind of
whatever to me but the the story with um
oh god they're making the tour of the
precinct yeah it was fun yeah it was a
lot of fun
who was that guy i know who were those
both of them looked looked familiar look
it up do the look up john you know you
like to look them up yeah let's give
credit where it's due to that guy had
the eyes i'm like i figured who played
steve urkel
uh julia white i haven't seen him in
years and i was like that looks like it
could be an old version of him uh yeah
he's he's definitely not old enough to
be this guy but but i see where you're
kind of coming sure he's yeah
because he still hosts things and stuff
oh i've never seen him
he does yeah
yeah he he's around still and he's not
quite that old
but this dude like i feel like this guy
is like a character actor um okay do it
john you gotta go here we go
here we go
richard penn plays fake holt what's he
been in he's been in
he was in an inappropriate comedy oh my
god i thought they were like celebrity
guest stars no he's done a lot of tv
that's the thing is like you've probably
seen his face but i'm i'm trying to see
what like the most record he's on an
episode of friends as a doctor
he oh he's playing a lot of doctors
done a lot of voiceover work okay so
he's been around television forever yeah
he's one of those actors who makes a
living doing this but he's not famous
yeah yeah yeah he's been on most of the
major
shows and things and then amanda rivas
he's a very ugly actor yeah
same kind of thing probably more like
low budget films and knockoff movies
than tv but there you go yeah i thought
they were both oh she's an uncredited
nurse in death proof so there you go i
know yeah very unattractive yeah
person breaker her credit is attractive
woman
so uh prison break at least begs differ
but yeah uh the the storyline there was
that was amusing and i like the ongoing
joke about
rosa wanting to sleep with him i know
we didn't see it happen there's still a
possibility maybe they'll bring him back
for that maybe he'll be the new uh nick
cannon and not show up but show up every
once in a while but you never see her
sexually excited i know this party
that's part of the fun yeah she was
saying
that jason mandzukic get away with a lot
more edgy jokes than this show normally
does yeah i didn't know you could say
dildo on network tv yeah
they said a lot of things yeah and i was
like oh i can't believe you're saying
that and then even like the violent bits
too yeah there's like so many ways to
get away with the edgy comedy here yeah
it's good that was really funny that was
that was a really funny episode it
hooked me right away at the very
beginning
and uh i i found myself really caring
like i hope you want them to work like i
was so worried for him at the end like
i'm glad he's back but if he was gonna
go terrible yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
probably unsustainable but i just want
them to trust each other and i want him
to like i loved that that whole thing
because you could see it coming but
still like the way he sold it was like i
believe that he actually likes jake and
wants to feel comfortable with him is
kind of turning to him as you know a
friend and a
and a help for transition
true that john it's a good relationship
saying true words i try to as much as i
can all right guys well what do you
think about jason manzoukis
leave your thoughts
while we are doing a page
brandon benzie
brandon
we don't know you oh we just know you've
been part of this patreon page
i suspect that you
are an undercover patron
for blind wave that's right trying to
steal our formula blind wave has sent
you in because they refuse to pledge but
they want to make sure that we're not
doing as good of a job at our patreon
keeping their eyes on us i know you're a
mole you don't really want this shout
out brandon benzie you're just here to
help out you're for ohio buddies aren't
you huh
it's all ohio with you benzie i'm on to
you man i'm gonna track down your family
i'm gonna track down your wife and kids
that's right i'm gonna track down your
great great grandmother
i'm gonna track them all down future
generations and i'm gonna tell them that
their little brandon benzies a snitch
for the greatest reaction channel out
there
but the best dudes you'll ever meet on
the internet blind wave
i don't even know why they're sending
you in here
ice email our videos to them every
single day
not a response i've been trying
brandon
dude just come clean man come clean
that's all we have we're ready to accept
you into
the super sexy reject nation you can
keep leaking info just let us know we
don't care man
are you one of those places that like
i'm not even going to make the joke
yeah you could have heard the joke if
you just
whoa look at your profile pic yeah look
at that look at that brandon oh no way
man it's gotta be fake you're too good
looking in this photo yeah
you're too good looking in this video
it's either good lighting or you have a
cool hair color thing going on but
either way look at that all black
everything little shadow behind you oh
man dude you're either someone who would
seduce my fiance or would be a villain
in one of the matrix movies one of the
two which hotel did you take a haltaway
picture in
to get this profile pic i don't think
it's a hotel it looks like a carpeted
ground is it an apartment building
he's clearly in front of a mirror john
it's like a hallway there's hell there's
a couple of doors and the one could have
an exit sign above it
would there be a mirror there in the
hotel you know maybe they want people to
make sure they look good before entering
their rooms because it's just that fancy
of a hotel you have to like suppose that
could be hardwood
i feel like it's i think you're right i
think it's carpet goddammit brandon
where are you located where are you in
this picture
and where are you while you're listening
to this just give us updates on your
location at all times it would have been
a perfect smash to black at the
the lion god damn it brandon where are
you and then you just
kill this
okay i'll smash the black right there
and then after the smashing black i'll
include this
[Music]